My oncologist agreed to write orders for monthly CEAN's CA2729 Tuberbarker lambs.
He said, those are the only relevant ones for me.
Is that good enough?
Back when I had active tumors, I ran the CA153 and 199.
None of them were ever really out of range except for the first 153.
And then everything went down after that.
Well, is that good enough?
Well, I'd say no.
I mean, it's better than not running any of them, but especially if this last comment,
the year 153 was out of range at one point in time or was elevated at one point in time.
That's going to be probably the one that would be elevated again.
If, you know, your cancer, you know, came back as active.
So I would make the argument that this is the one that was elevated before.
Can you at least run this?
I just don't get it.
Is it any skin off their bones to run that again, you know, good as sinks.
Here's a person with history and breast cancer.
Why did they have to be argumentative?
Why won't insurance pay for two more tests?
What's it cost them $20 or something?
Give me a break. It's just so stupid.
Yeah, I mean, I'm not knocking you.
I mean, just do whatever you can, but I would make the argument that this one was out of range before.
Can you please just run this one again as well?
So, yeah, it's frustrating.